hi there day 70. you know i've got
basically a month to go
um today i want to talk about
uh you know sometimes talk about big
picture learning and bits and pieces
learning
today i want to use a different image
and that is sort of the big basket
and the small basket or even
call it calipers or
whatever
and what i mean by that by that is you
know i was i mentioned the other day
that uh despite the fact that i've
really improved my ability to understand
for example uh
quite a difficult con podcast
and i mentioned that uh some weeks ago i
had an interview with someone from the
local korean newspaper and i was able to
answer questions and talk about the
things that we're doing and and felt wow
am i ever doing well
and then i went to the restaurant
where
this is a sushi restaurant where they
have a korean
uh they're all korean actually but
there's one particular waitress that i
speak to and i spoke to her when i
started
and then i started trying to make small
talk again and i felt i didn't do any
better than i did two months ago
uh partly because there's so much noise
i can't hear what she's saying
partly because i can't anticipate what
she's gonna say
and so i struggle
and so then someone said in a comment to
that video you know that's interesting i
had always
assumed that you needed to first learn
the small chit chat small talk before
you could progress to
more
call it more intelligent conversation or
the ability to understand
more difficult texts
well that kind of got me thinking i i
for example when i studied czech i
didn't
well with russian i must have listened
for a year and a half before i started
speaking with czech i think was at least
six months
listening to fairly difficult stuff and
then of course when i started to speak i
i struggled and stumbled but eventually
it came along so
i sort of realized that my method of
learning
it really is that i don't worry too much
about the small talk chit chat it
doesn't matter that much to me i have no
real pressing need to engage in small
talk chit chat
um but i am motivated by these
interesting content items and so i kind
of liken it to
you know i scoop up a lot of stuff and i
keep on scooping up a lot of stuff in
this huge basket and it's all swimming
around in there
maybe interacting you know maybe it's
fish and they're kind of interacting in
some way and
and i scoop up more and more all in this
big in this big
basket
and eventually more and more of that
stays
whereas if i go and grab
stuff with a little basket and throw it
onto the shore
i find i tend to lose a lot of it it
could be reviewing
you know
endings of verbs reviewing certain
patterns of speech i mean you have to do
some of it you have to do some of it all
along you have to do some of it at the
very beginning and you have to do it
sort of regularly throughout but all of
i find all of those kinds of reviews of
structure and of grammatical rules and
case endings
uh stays with you for a very short time
it's like you picked it up in a small
fishnet and you put it on the shore and
you looked at it and pretty soon it kind
of all went away a little bit remains
but mostly it kind of goes away whereas
the stuff that we pick up in this big
basket and that's what i do when i'm
listening to difficult stuff and reading
difficult stuff and accumulating all
these words very few of them do i have
time to review and flash cards most of
the time i'm just meeting them again
highlighted in yellow at link in
in you know the next lesson and stuff
and it's just it's always there and
and eventually it starts to settle
and
again you go back to the rules and that
but eventually as it settles you've got
more and more of a of sort of a
background
of experience
against which you can then apply these
little rules that you're constantly
learning and forgetting learning and
forgetting learning and forgetting
and so i guess what i'm saying is you
need a combination of the big basket the
big
fishing net
and the small fishnet
and you don't necessarily like i've
personally found that i just cannot nail
down stuff at the beginning
so knowing that i can't nail it down i'm
not disappointed when i can't remember
certain obvious words or obvious
structures
i know that in time they will start to
solidify
so
thinking of that person's comment i
can't remember who it was
you know that we progressed from small
sort of chit chat
social conversation to more complicated
conversation
in fact
i mean it also depends on your
opportunity if i were surrounded by
native speakers i would be developing
that ability much more quickly i'm not
surrounded by native speakers so i rely
more on
this other strategy i'm not saying it's
bad to rely on
you know to to spend more time on the on
the chit chat
but my eventual goal as i always say is
to have intelligent conversations on a
wide variety of subjects to be able to
read the newspaper
read books you know listen to an
interesting podcast such as the one i'm
using right now and to understand it and
enjoy it that's what i want to get to
anyway so there you have it that's the
big fishnet and the small fish net
approach to language learning
i will finish off with a few
housekeeping keeping items people are
saying my
microphone is not loud enough
i think that really only applies to
when we use my iphone to video things in
the office
and if anyone has any suggestions on how
to
capture the sound better that using the
iphone um you know as a
video
you know
making device
um please let me know i think the sound
with my
snowflake here when i do this in front
of the computer is good enough please
let me know
um
another thing i walked in the dog again
today it was raining it rained a lot
last night
uh i'm gonna finish off by the way with
a few shots from the forest showing the
falls
but today because of the rain the
stream was a torrent
the falls were just
roaring
and there's an area where normally gordy
likes to go in and splash around and he
took one look
at the torrent
and i was afraid that he was going to
jump in the water and he might have been
gone down the falls
and he took one look at it and didn't
miss a beat didn't even bother going
down there whereas normally just
zooms down there so he's smarter than he
looks
okay that's it bye for now here we have
a falls again
and where's that my friend gordy
gordy don't be shy gordy
say hello yeah
good boy
and then we'll walk up here now
and continue on our way